we have this uh this tweet this tweet
from clay Travis The Washington Post
which has lost 500 000 subscribers in
the past year has announced layoffs are
coming to the paper the meeting didn't
go well oh let's play the meeting for
you
agreement
look at they're wearing masks
we'll have more information as we move
forward thank you very much
as these people wear masks and wine
about what are you going to do to
protect people's jobs I uh we're talking
about neurolink and I'm like these
people will sign up day one that's and I
think I wonder if Elon knows that
he looked at these people and he was
like these people would put masks on
their asses if they were told to do it
by the government they're going to get
the neural link when we tell them to do
it they got the apps the mobile apps
they got the ID cards they all did it
who didn't
well it's the conservatives the
Libertarians it's the anarchists it's
the right whatever they want to call it
these are the people who are like nah
how do you convince them to do it you
got to win them over that was the point
of the tweet I was making basically like
as if this is going to happen people
these people government's going to come
out and say oh you know as a pandemic
and there's Terror so you got to get the
chip once you get the chip then you can
go to your Starbucks
but people like us were going to be like
nah I don't need Starbucks I think they
would also really love those Chinese
covet tests that they're applying to
people up there you know what uh but but
I I do believe that there is going to be
a larger Financial Reckoning I I think
Elon is trying to
um uh do as many things fiscally
responsible at Twitter right now because
I think he sees the storm is coming
especially financially that is going to
be correlated with centralized forces
pushing a Ubi pushing Central Bank
digital currencies pushing for a
solution that of course is going to
greatly benefit them and give them more
power over everyone else so I think
these layoffs are just more layoffs to
come already there was so much uh
layoffs in the tech industry when it
came to Amazon when it came to Facebook
when it came to Twitter these are not
accidental layoffs these are layoffs in
anticipation of the larger Financial
Market being turned upside down because
the last three years we prioritized
safety shutting down small mom and hot
businesses over of course Walmart Costco
and all these other billionaires that
got richer more than they ever did
before in their entire human history
when we look at this larger transfer of
wealth it was a lot of money when we
look at how much money the US federal
reserve prints it's a lot of money
there's going to be ramifications for
that I think this is the beginning sign
of a lot of other businesses that are
going to be laying people off in droves
to come the next few weeks and months
what do you think financially Gene
What's Happening Here I I think you I
think almost everything you've said is
is I would agree with 100 and we we are
facing a financial Reckoning we're
because it's not it's not just issues
like this but it's government with with
the printing money with spending money
on just anything just you know dealing
it out like it's candy at Halloween is
not a good way to run your Society so
there is a reckoning that's coming I I
don't know what the in the uh influence
with the Washington Post though uh with
this with this particular video I mean
it it sounds like they've lost
subscribers from what I understand yeah
half a million I think half a million
that's a ton of folks that's a ton of
people but look I mean you just you
can't you can't run a business if you
lose half a million subscribers you
can't continue to end so hopefully it's
a lesson that you know hey maybe maybe
they could actually try to report on
some things a little bit more of a
balanced Direction but they're not going
to take that lesson these workers are
going to vote communist in two seconds
right yeah Washington Post is going to
shut down or they're going to get fired
and they're going to say but our jobs
are essential what do we do I know let's
vote for the government to nationalize
The Washington Post that's a good idea
then our jobs will be secured what they
leave out of those ideas is that it's
basically our job is secured by forcing
other people to make food for us at
gunpoint doesn't the CIA have enough
black budget money to finance The
Washington Post aren't they already
doing it I mean come on let's be real
here when when their reporting is just
based on Anonymous Intel sources all the
time you would think the CIA would throw
them a few bucks well come on CIA you
could do a little bit better Amazon also
Jeff Bezos has a lot of connections with
the CIA so just something to think about
here but but this is a big problem here
because Vice news is also reporting that
there's going to be layoffs there's
going to be restrictions at the company
look at just what happened to CNN it
doesn't pay to be a shill so that's a
big Learning lesson from all the
corporate media that's that's dealing
with a big Reckoning as Independent
Media I mean you're doing good I'm doing
good we're growing yeah we're I mean if
we had anywhere near half a million
subscribers that would be just
absolutely Bonkers Game Changer like I
mean absolutely five I just do the math
500 000 members and we and it's 10 bucks
a month to be a member at timcast.com
yeah you're talking 60 million dollars a
year at that point that's a crazy amount
of cash to be dealing with you could
hire thousands of people you could you
could you could just basically gut all
of your competition and hire up their
their employees if you had that much
money these are spoiled brats that are
getting the diamond pacifier slapped out
of their mouths okay that's what's
happening here nothing else more I got a
question so you know Elon he rolled out
the new color verification and uh if you
pull this up we got the Washington Post
they get a yellow badge and they say
that you know yellow means business and
I'm like I I could not but notice that
all of the news outlets are yellow
is that a is that was that on purpose is
Elon Musk behind the scenes laughing and
mocking them yellow journalism it's a
reference to just garbage you know
garbage in yellow bellies uh stocks and
Hammer had a very interesting tweet
highlighting the which one
no no no he he said that this is the
universal symbol for propaganda and
sensationalism and well he's not wrong
but the post-millennial I think is
yellow yeah and uh it's just you know I
don't think it they just made news
organizations yellow I just think that's
funny it's like wink wink nudge nudge I
like it when I'm looking at the
Washington Post struggling right now I
think what's happening is these old
things that used to rely on text because
that was all they had in the 1960s and
70s and 80s and stuff like that you
didn't have internet video and it was
very expensive to have a TV network
they're still relying on this lame-ass
text like text is fine for what it is
which is to get a piece of data across
it there's no emotional value so when
you're trying to explain emotions use
internet video you need to be hiring
people to be making internet videos cut
down on your overhead wait they can be
working from home man stop giving them
tips and advice
they don't need the help they shouldn't
get the employees I care about their
shields for the CIA don't give them
advice either please I want you to to
understand what's going on with the old
Guard versus a new guard and I'll use a
very simple analogy I want you to
imagine a large waffle got a big waffle
on your plate with all the little nooks
and crannies that they're called the
holes in the waffles because I remember
the echo commercial and so you know what
this podcast is is delicious organic
fresh maple syrup maybe from Vermont and
as it is poured over that waffle it gets
into all those little nooks and crannies
along with the butter and it's perfect
every bite what the Old Guard media is
is like taking a sheet of paper and
placing it on top of the waffle it
doesn't get into the cracks my point is
the reason why these kinds of shows in
this kind of news is taking off taking
off is because we don't just say
headline as Roe v Wade repeal looms
video game industry stays silent what we
do is we expand upon that we get in
depth with it we all talk about it we
bounce ideas around them we ask the
audience talk about it so what I mean by
filling all the nooks and crannies is
we're trying to hit every crevice every
point that we can whereas with the
Washington Post does they don't even
they don't even give you a blanket view
they don't even cover the waffle they
they give you this Twisted line of
butter that goes in a random Direction
and you're like that's it what is this
it's not even the real story
they are selectively filling certain
points to make you think wrong things
I would say that Independent Media is
raw milk butter Washington Post is
canola oil that's the way for me to help
people understand this personally myself
but uh margarine yeah yeah exactly but
but you know Gene what do you see
happening because you know more and more
Independent Media is getting a bigger
voice we're becoming more prominent how
do you see this kind of media landscape
moving forward because it does seem like
the old guard the dinosaur media the
prostitutes the horror stream media
they're just going down in droves and I
it's it's you know I I hate to celebrate
something negative but it's good to see
a Changing of the Guard myself look it's
it's really good to see a changing the
guard the stuff that you guys are doing
the stuff that other folks are doing is
fantastic because you're covering issues
that people care about you're talking
about things in depth in a way that
people care about not in a way that some
person based in Washington DC is
deciding how to tell you about the
information you are engaging on it
you're having an in-depth discussion I
mean it's it's free it's open people
like to listen to it they're a part of
the conversation station but another
piece of this though with the with the
old Legacy Media that you know I don't I
don't hear a ton of folks talking about
is so much of the Legacy Media has been
centralized and nationalized right and
so every story is coming out of
Washington every story's coming out of
uh of DC or New York whatever local news
truly local news we once had local
newspapers all across this country that
reported on things that affected things
in communities things that actually
affected folks everyday lives and those
have all gone by the wayside and I think
personally that's a huge tragedy because
folks don't even know what's going on in
their own neighborhoods their own towns
their own their own local cities but yet
they can probably tell you what you know
Nancy Pelosi said
um you know or what Donald Trump said or
what anyone said because everything's
become so nationalized and if we can get
if we can support local Outlets again or
find a way to get the local news covered
and then with the independent Outlets
cover the actual issues I think would be
in a much better place as a society
I I think also another solution for Elon
Musk there instead of just having yellow
verified badges you should have glowing
verified badges for all
problem didn't see connected Muse
organizations that aren't really news
organizations they're just doing PR for
some of the richest people in this world
and the special interests who are really
in charge pulling the strings behind Joe
Biden well that's just my two cents and
and you know what he should do these
verification badges should not be
optional so like he's basically saying
if you want to get verified you gotta
get Twitter blue and if you're an
official Advertiser you get the the
business verification there should just
be Bots that are operated as sock
puppets by U.S intelligence agencies he
knows and he gives them all like a
glowing you know verification badge and
when you highlight it it says this
account is verified because it's run by
uh governmental intelligence operation
that would be fantastic yeah absolutely
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time